WE WILL SEE YOU THEN.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
DAMAGING DOMESTIC SPYING
OPERATIONS, EXCUSE ME, IT
CATCHES YOU IN THE THROAT EVEN
SAYING IT APPEARED THAT THE
MISTING MIKE DOMESTIC SPYING
OPERATION THAT OBAMA RAN FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE AGAINST POLITICAL
ENEMIES MY GENERAL PLAN AMONG
THEM.
TODAY THE FALLOUT FROM THE
SCANDAL AND AN UPDATE FOR YOU
ABOUT THAT, BUT FIRST TONIGHT
COMMIT HAS BEEN CLOSE TO THREE
WEEKS SINCE THE STATE OF GEORGIA
BEGAN TO GRADUALLY LOOSEN ITS
CORONAVIRUS LOCKDOWN.
STARTING LATE APRIL, HAIR
SALONS, BOWLING ALLEYS,
BARBERSHOPS AND GYMS TO REOPEN.
THREE DAYS LATER RESTAURANT AND
THEATERS FOLLOWED.
HOSPITALS ONCE AGAIN ALLOWED TO
PERFORM ALL NEEDED SURGERIES.
THEY COULD STOP PRETENDING THAT
CORONAVIRUS WAS THE ONLY MEDICAL
PROBLEM THAT PATIENCE FACED.
IT IS NOT.
AND SOMETHING ESPECIALLY RADICAL
ABOUT WHAT GEORGIA DID, BUT YOU
WOULDN’T KNOW THAT IF YOU ARE
WATCHING TELEVISION THAT WEEK.
THE DECISION WAS DESCRIBED THERE
IS THE MOST RECKLESS, PUBLIC
HEALTH DECISIONS SINCE 9 OUT OF
10 FAMILY DOCTORS ENDORSED CAMEL
CIGARETTES.
UNTOLD MILLIONS WOULD DIE
BECAUSE GEORGIA WAS REOPENING.
THE STATE OF GEORGIA WOULD BE
FLATTENED BY A TIDAL WAVE OF
CORPSES.
IT WAS THAT DANGEROUS.
EVEN STACY ABRAMS TOOK A BREAK
FROM CAMPAIGNING FOR VICE TO
VICE PRESIDENT TO OFFER HER
ASSESSMENT.
>> WE HONESTLY DON’T UNDERSTAND
THE MAYORS OF THE CITIES WHO
EXPRESSED DEEP CONCERNS.
AS OUR SCIENTISTS COMMIT MAKES
NO SENSE DUMB ACCENTS AND IT
PUTS MORE GEORGIANS AT RISK.
>> Tucker: SHE SEEMS TO KNOW
WHAT SHE’S TALKING ABOUT.
YOU SHOULD KNOW STACY A STACY
ABRAMS IS DELUSIONAL AND SHE
ANNOUNCED SHE WAS THE GOVERNOR
OF GEORGIA ONE STEP FROM
CLAIMING NAPOLEON.
NOW ABRAMS IMAGINED A PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS, BEST OF HUMOR
AND NOD AND LOOK INTERESTED.
NOT A SCIENTIST EITHER IN COME
AT A MALE FEMINIST BUT STILL A
STRONG VIEW ON EPIDEMIOLOGY.
HE WAS SO UPSET BY PEOPLE IN
GEORGIA MIGHT GO OUTSIDE WITHOUT
PERMISSION THAT HE SUDDENLY
FOUND HIMSELF ARGUING THAT
EVERYBODY MUST OBEY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
IF THAT SOUNDS INSANE TO YOU,
YOU ARE NOT ALONE, AND FOR THE
RECORD, GEORGIA DOES NOT MEET
THE WHITE HOUSE GUIDELINES
COMMIT DOESN’T HAVE A 14 DAY
TRAJECTORY OF CASES.
IT HAS TESTED 90,000 PEOPLE OF A
POPULATION OF 10 MILLION.
MAYORS IN GEORGIA ARE DESCRIBING
THE GOVERNOR’S DECISION AS
RECKLESS, DANGEROUS, AND
ILLOGICAL.
WE WENT THE VOICE OF OVERPRICED
BROOKLYN.
WE MUST DO WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE
TELLS US, HE SCREAMS ON MSNBC!
THAT IS HOW DANGEROUS IT WAS.
MARK THIS DAY, WROTE ONE LONG
TIME WASHINGTON REPORTED BECAUSE
TWO AND THREE WEEKS FROM NOW,
THE GEORGIA DEATH TOLL IS BLOOD
ON GOVERNOR BRYAN KIM’S HANDS.
WELL IF IT HAPPENS, WE DID, IN
FACT, MARKED THAT DAY APRIL 25TH
2020 WHEN THE REOPENING’S BEGAN,
AND THAT DAY, GEORGIA HAD 650
NEW CASES OF CORONAVIRUS.
YESTERDAY WHICH WAS 18 DAYS
LATER, GEORGIA HAD A TOTAL OF
555 CASES OF CORONAVIRUS.
INFECTIONS AND DEATH IN GEORGIA
HAVE BEEN DECLINING SINCE EARLY
APRIL AND THAT’S WHERE THEY
BEGAN TO REOPEN IT.
THERE IS STILL SICK PEOPLE IN
THE STATE AND SOME OF THEM WILL
DIE, BUT AS OF TONIGHT, GEORGE’S
NUMBERS, THE ACTUAL NUMBERS ARE
NO WORSE THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
AND THAT TELLS US A LOT.
WE SHOULD BE THRILLED BY THIS
NEWS BECAUSE IF AMERICA CAN
BEGIN TO RETURN TO NORMAL,
STOLEN RIGHTS FROM THE
POPULATION, MAY BE TREAT
CITIZENS LIKE ADULTS ONCE AGAIN,
AND NOT COURT MEDICAL DISASTERS.
YOU WOULD THINK OUR LEADERSHIP
WOULD BE RACING TO THE PODIUM TO
SHARE THIS GREAT NEWS, BUT OF
COURSE THEY ARE NOT.
JUST THE OPPOSITE, IN FACT THEY
ARE DOUBLING DOWN ON
AUTHORITARIANS.
THEY ENJOYED BEING IN CONTROL OF
YOUR LIFE.
THEY DO NOT PLAN TO RELINQUISH
THE POWER THEY RECEIVE FROM THIS
PANDEMIC ANYTIME SOON, IF EVER.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES TO
EXTEND ITS LOCKDOWN THROUGH THE
END OF JULY.
CITIZENS THERE WILL HAVE TO WEAR
A MASK AT ALL TIMES, EVEN WHEN
THEY ARE OUTSIDE WHERE THE RISK
OF TRANSMISSION IS MINIMAL.
HE DID NOT EXPLAIN THE SCIENCE
BEHIND THESE COMMANDS, AND TOLD
THE CITY, SURE, FOR THE VIRUS,
LIKE WE WILL NEVER GO BACK TO
NORMAL.
AND THE MAYOR DID NOT MENTION
THAT IT IS POSSIBLE, IN FACT
LIKELY THERE WILL NEVER BE A
CURE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
WHATEVER.
MOST DIDN’T ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT
IT BUT QUICKLY ENDORSED THE
WHOLE THING.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SAGAN, THREE
MORE MONTHS.
I CAN’T SURVIVE THIS.
IT IS A SMALL BUSINESS COME I
CAN’T SURVIVE THIS AS SOMEONE
OUT OF WORK.
>> OF COURSE I AGREE WITH THE
DECISIONS THAT THE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUNDS IN PARTICULAR VENUE AND
LOCATION.
SO YES, IT IS INCONVENIENT, BUT
IT IS EVEN MORE INCONVENIENT IF
YOU ARE GOING TO BE INFECTED OR
WORSE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IT IS
INCONVENIENT, YEAH, IT IS
INCONVENIENT BUT NOT AS
INCONVENIENT AS BEING INFECTED
WITH A DEADLY DISEASE SAYS LUCY.
A GOOD TALKING POINT, BY THE
WIFE A 26-YEAR-OLD STAFFER WROTE
IT, BUT A FACTUAL MATTER, IT IS
WRONG.
FOR THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS, THE LOCKDOWNS ARE FAR
WORSE THAN GETTING SICK WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS.
IF YOU ARE UNDER 60, THE ODDS OF
DYING FROM THIS ARE FEW OF ONE
AND 1,000 PROBABLY LESS THAN
ONE IN 10,000 AND THE ODDS ARE
DESTROYING YOUR LIFE, THOSE
CHANCES ARE FIRE TO FAR HIGHER
THAN THAT.
ASK YOURSELF HOW MANY HEALTHY
MIDDLE-AGE PEOPLE DO YOU KNOW
THAT DIED FROM THIS VIRUS?
MAYBE YOU KNOW SOMEONE.
THOUGH MANY PEOPLE DO YOU KNOW
THE WHO ARE NOW UNEMPLOYED AND
TERRIFIED OF THE FUTURE?
PROBABLY A LOT, AND
GOVERNOR JAY INSLEE NOT A MATH
GUY.
HE HAS NOT CALCULATED
POSSIBILITIES LIKE THIS BUT
JAY INSLEE BELIEVES EVERYONE IN
WASHINGTON STATE FACES THE REAL
LIKELIHOOD OF DYING FROM THE
VIRUS AND THAT’S WHY HE HAS
ORDERED OFFICIALS OF THE STATE
TO TRACK WHO GOES TO RESTAURANTS
AND WHO THEY EAT WITH BECAUSE
THAT IS NOT A CHINESE POLICE
STATE TACTIC OR ANYTHING.
>> THIS CONTACT TRACING,
OBVIOUSLY, IF YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO’S BECOME SICK AND THEY WERE
SITTING RIGHT NEXT TO A PERSON
AT A RESTAURANT, TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THAT PERSON COULD BE
VERY VALUABLE FOR THEIR HEALTH
TO TRY TO SAVE THEIR LIFE.
AND SO BE PUT THAT IN PLACE.
>> Tucker: YEAH COMMIT IS KIND
OF WEIRD THE AUTHORITIES ARE
TAKING NOTES ON WHO YOU ARE HAVI
FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH SO SUBMIT.
IT’S NOT LIKE POLITICIANS EVER
MISUSE THAT INFORMATION OR
ANYTHING SO SLEEP WELL.
DON’T FORGET TO SEND IN A BLOOD
SAMPLE SO THE GOVERNMENT CAN
SEQUENCE YOUR DNA FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH REASONS.
NOBODY IN AMERICA IS ENJOYING
ALL OF THIS MORE THAN MICHIGAN
GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WHITMER THE
MOST MEDIOCRE PEOPLE WHO LOVE
FASCISM THE MOST THAT GIVES THEM
THE POWER THEY NEVER DREAMED
THEY WOULD HAVE AND INDEED,
DON’T DESERVE.
LET MAYOR WANTS THIS MOMENT TO
LAST FOREVER.
SHE SAID ANYONE WHO DARES TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT IT, SHE WENT ON
ABC YESTERDAY AND DISMISSED ANY
CITIZEN WHO DISAGREES WITH HER,
NEEDLESS TO SAY, AS A RACIST!
AND SHE PROMISES THAT
DISOBEDIENT CITIZENS AND
MICHIGAN WILL BE PUNISHED WITH
MORE SEVERE LOCKDOWNS.
>> THESE HAVE BEEN REALLY
POLITICAL RALLIES FOR PEOPLE
WITH CONFEDERATE FLAGS AND
SYMBOLISM, SYMBOLISM AND CALLING
FOR VIOLENCE.
RACIST AND MISOGYNISTIC AND I
ASKED THAT EVERYBODY WHO HAS A
PLATFORM USE IT TO CALL ON
PEOPLE TO OBSERVE THE BEST
PRACTICES PROMULGATED BY THE SEA
TO STOP ENCOURAGING THIS
BEHAVIOR BECAUSE IT ONLY MAKES
IT THAT MUCH MORE PRECARIOUS FOR
US TO TRY TO REENGAGE OUR
ECONOMY, WHICH IS WHAT EVERYONE
SAYS THEY WANT US TO BE ABLE TO
DO.
>> Tucker: YEAH, NOT ONLY IS
IT RACIST, IT IS DANGEROUS TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND RACISM.
SHE WAS ASKED IF SHE HAD
EVIDENCE, PROOF THAT PROTESTERS
WERE ACTUALLY SPREADING THE
VIRUS, AND YOU WILL BE SURPRISED
TO LEARN SHE DIDN’T.
BY THE WAY, THAT QUESTION IS
MASSAGED IN THIS TIP SO SHUT UP,
BIGOT.
SOME PEOPLE IN MICHIGAN ARE
GROWING TIRED OF THIS
PERFORMANCE.
CARL MENKE OWNS A BARBERSHOP AND
HE WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO CUT
HAIR.
AUTHORITIES WON’T LET HIM DO
THAT.
THEY PREFER TO SEND HIM WELFARE
CHECKS INSTEAD.
THAT IS NOT THE COUNTRY WANTS TO
LIVE IN THOUGH.
>> 177.
I’VE ALWAYS WORKED.
HAVE NEVER LOOKED FOR HANDOUTS.
I DON’T EVEN KNOW WHAT THEY ARE.
SOMEBODY TO CALL ME AND SAY WHY
DIDN’T YOU GET ON FOOD STAMPS?
WELL, I DON’T WANT FOOD STAMPS.
I WANT TO WORK.
WHEN OUR GOVERNOR SAID, WE WILL
HAVE ANOTHER 28 DAYS, I WENT TO
MY KNEES.
I CAN’T TAKE ANOTHER 28 DAYS.
ALL OF US AS AMERICANS NEED TO
BEGIN TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OURSELVES.
YOU KNOW?
I FEEL THAT THE GOVERNMENT IS
NOT MY MOTHER, NEVER HAS BEEN,
YOU KNOW, AND MATTER OF FACT,
THIS ADMINISTRATION FOR THE MOST
PART, I’VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
LONGER THAN THEY’VE BEEN ALIVE.
>> Tucker: GRETCHEN WHITMER
WAS NOT AMUSED BY THAT.
THE GOVERNOR IS NOT MY MOM?
MISOGYNY, BY THE WAY, CUTTING
HERE IS RACIST.
SO THE ADMINISTRATION TRIED TO
SHUT HIM DOWN WITH A COURT ORDER
BECAUSE THERE’S NOTHING ELSE
GOING ON IN MICHIGAN RIGHT NOW.
A JUDGE RESISTED THAT IT WAS TOO
FAR.
SO SIMPLY REVOKED THE BARBERS
LICENSE.
NOW, HE IS SHUT DOWN FOR GOOD
AND WILL BE EVEN WHEN THE
LOCKDOWN IS FINALLY ENDED.
STOP WHINING AND TAKE YOUR
WELFARE CHECK, BIGOT.
THIS IS INSANITY, OBVIOUSLY AND
AT SOME POINT WE WILL LOOK BACK
IN SHAME AS WE CONSIDER IT.
POLITICIANS WILL ALWAYS SEE THEM
MAXIMUM POWER OF POWER THEY
HAVE.